a bein bended household chores last
weekend together they earned $50 that
looks like an interesting statement let
me underline that together they earned
$50 and Abby earned $10 more than Ben so
they also tell us let me underline that
Abby earned $10 more than Ben how much
did each earn so that's the first
question that we have to answer and they
say if you were to use the graph above
and I put it on the side here which
strategy is most useful in helping you
find the answer to the problem so
there's kind of a meta-level question of
how do we answer that first question
find an equation for the blue line Reds
y-intercept find the points of
intersection fair enough
so let's just think about that first
question then we can answer this late
later depending on how we answered that
first question so that first statement
together they earned $50 what does that
tell us well if we say that a x' if we
say that Abby's earnings are represented
by a and Ben's earnings are represented
by B that tells us that a plus B must be
$50 so a plus B have to be equal to $50
Abby's earnings plus Ben's earnings are
50 together they earned $50 that's all
that statement is telling us and if we
see how they graph things here on the
vertical axis what we normally associate
with the y axis they graphed Abby's
earnings or this is Abby's earnings
right there so we could say this is the
a axis and then on the horizontal axis
what we normally associate with the x
axis they they've charted Ben's earnings
so we could say that this is the B axis
so if we were to just map this into the
traditional slope-intercept form we
don't have X's and Y's here we have B's
and A's so we just want to express a in
terms of B the vertical variable in
terms of the horizontal variable that's
just like the y equals MX plus B form
and the easiest way to do that is just
subtract B from both sides of this
equation and we get a is equal to
negative B plus 50 so in this situation
you have a slope of negative one let me
write this down slope of negative one
that's what's multiplying the
independent variable and then you have a
y-intercept of 50 or maybe we should say
an A intercept but all right y-intercept
because that's what we're familiar
you can do this is also like the Y or
the vertical axis y-intercept of 50 and
you can see they graph that you have a a
interceptor or y intercept of 50 and the
slope is negative 1 if we move 20 in the
positive x direction we are moving down
20 in d or we're going 20 in the
negative vertical direction or in the
negative a direction if we go if we go
50 in the positive I shouldn't say X
direction the positive B direction we go
down 50 in the a direction so the slope
is negative 1 so this red line right
here is the graph that depicts this
first constraint this first constraint
it's important to realize that look all
this graph shows is all the different
possible combinations of Abby's and
Ben's earnings given this only this
first constraint
maybe Abby made $50 and Ben earned zero
dollars maybe Ben earned $50 and Abby
earned $0 maybe they both earned $25
everything on this line would be a valid
combination of Abby's and Ben's earnings
given the constraint that they earned
$50 combined now the second statement
Abby earned $10 more than Ben so if we
were to write that that's saying that a
B is equal to Ben's earnings plus $10
Abby earned $10 more than Ben and here
the slope is 1 slope is equal to 1 you
see that right there there's an implicit
one multiplying times this B and then
the y-intercept is 10 y-intercept is 10
and they graph that here the y-intercept
is 10 and the slope is 1 you move ten in
the positive B direction you move up 10
in the positive a direction so this blue
line represents all of the possible
combinations of a B and Ben's earnings
if you only had if you only had this
constraint that Abby earned $10 more
than Ben have been earned zero dollars a
Buren's 10 if Ben earns $10 a viren's 20
if Ben earns $60 a B earns 70 now we
aren't dealing with only the blue
constraint or only the red constraint
we're dealing with both of them we know
that both of them are true so whatever
earnings Abby and Ben made they have to
satisfy both
strains or they have to sit on both of
these lines now what is the only point
that is sitting on both of these lines
well the only point that sits on both of
the lines is the intersection of those
lines that point right there is a valid
combination from the point of view of
the blue constraint that Abby earned $10
more than Ben and it's also a valid
point or valid combination from the
point of view of the red constraint that
Abby earned 50 Abby and Ben earned $50
so that point represents a Abbie's and
Ben's earnings that satisfy both
constraints and we can eyeball it right
here it looks like Abby earned $30 and
Ben earned $20 and that makes sense
combined 20 plus 30 or 30 plus 20 is $50
so we meet our first constraint and we
see that Abby thirty dollars made $10
more than Ben who only made 20 dollars
so if you look at the point of
intersection you will have solved the
problem ad we made thirty dollars been
earned 20 so answering this second so we
know the answer so Abby Abby earned $30
and Ben then earned $20 now answering
the second level meta-level question
which is the best strategy we see well
we had to find the points of
intersection so that is choice C we had
to find the lines point of intersection
finding these other things really
wouldn't have helped us solve the
problem